c'est à choisir obs pardon une carte
minute blonde vous devez porter cette
perruque blonde et répondre très
bêtement à mes questions pour la
perruque ça va être facile pour le reste
je suis pas sûr donnez moi s'il vous
plaît la perruque lointaine cheveux un
miroir parce que je sens sinon que
thierry va pas être tout à fait fair
play par rapport à cette transformation
alors je vais ressembler à françoise de
panafieu en deux secondes un grand mât
regardant l'écran que d'en bas ah oui
attendait alors attendez attendez
excusez moi
elle est bien là
enfin une grand portugaise je dois
montrer un soin ou c'est pas nécessaire
normalement ça va avec
ouais merde moi je me l'étais programmé
pour plus tard après françoise bien le
tueur est comme ça où tu passes ta
perruque à michel blanc à benoît gars je
vais déjà fait avec gérard opération